this is the main State Highway in
Hawke's Bay a cyclone Gabriel pushed
across New Zealand's North Island it cut
off roads and cities
it brought torrential rain and some wind
gusts reaching 140 kilometers an hour
leaving residents shaken
thunder and lightning and everything
last night was just horrific so
but the devastation is just
oh it just makes you makes you want to
cry to be honest
a storm began lushing the northern coast
on Sunday the damage in its wake led the
government to declare a state of
emergency for the third time in its
history it's the situation that new
zealanders have been waking up to this
morning a lot of families displaced a
lot of homes without power extensive
Damage Done across the country we'll be
throwing everything at this to make sure
we're providing as much support to the
response as possible
rescue efforts are
it's ra and the Defense Force has been
rallied residents have been advised to
stay away from rising Coastal Waters
many regions in the north were still
recovering from record rain for two
weeks ago on the east coast of the North
Island entire towns and settlements have
been cut off due to either Rising flood
waters or the roads going in and out of
these places have been cut off by slips
or Fallen trees in some places the
entire road is gone
hundreds of roads are impossible land is
continuing to slip under the weight of
torrential rain and tens of thousands of
people have no power
rescue workers say it's too early to
assess the extent of the damage but the
continuing storm is likely to hamper
rescue efforts
Al Jazeera